stay ready for my opportunities to to
put these paws on [ __ ] yeah
yeah [ __ ] you dude i want to [ __ ]
punch somebody
you can punch me nah nah bro i don't
know punch me bro it's cool bro
no stomach or in the face i mean the
face might i might bleed so
no you could do like a belly shot
i don't know if i could do you think i
could do i could do pretty probably
pretty good you think
[Music]
him bro
it was good he pulled his punch a little
bit i think
that's crazy dog
look at you smile that's a good shot
that's a good shot man
he pulled the punch i don't know if i
pulled it or not man well i have dreams
most famous person has ever punched me
really yeah for sure oh we could get
some i i dude i could i'm gonna text
some people then next time work your
fights i think i get jared leto to punch
you i'll fight any real fighter and i'm
gonna fight real fighters i know the
movie guys ain't gonna be there they
ain't gonna they ain't for it they don't
want the smoke
i'm gonna keep fighting i'm only 30. by
the time i'm 45
i would have the record and
uh
uh what's the word uh attributes or
whatever of mike tyson
because i i just who gets down like me i
don't know anyone nobody gets down like
me yeah i mean i don't i don't nobody
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one